depuis quelques années l'association
machine feuillane a toujours mis en
avant les produits locaux travailler
avec un réseau de producteurs pour
pouvoir fournir de la marchandise à des
prix très intéressants à la population
voilà c'est la fête des mères arrivent
on profite pour mettre de la marchandise
ya plusieurs manifestations sur l'année
mais particulièrement match
fête des mères donc nous avons des
concombres à 80 centimes le bio les
christophine à 80 centimes au sachant
très bien que la population adore les
cristaux pis c'est la période des fêtes
de mariages baptêmes communions donc la
population peut descendre chercher leur
copie
nous sommes une seule image de fête des
mères c'est une manière aussi de
revaloriser droit valoriser la
profession
oui qui est quand même en perdition
revalorisé nous avons plusieurs
confirmations toute l'année c'est vrai
on a eu le problème du marché ou machin
fruits elle a fait peu de manifestations
mais en manque de place
mais là ça on recommence tout doucement
et nous avons plusieurs programmations
pour l'année